une réforme des rythmes scolaires oui
dans ces conditions non c'est le mot
d'ordre lancé par le syndicat des
enseignants du premier degré ce mercredi
à Trapp jour de manifestation régionale
de l'ensemble des départements
d'Île-de-France l'idée de réformer les
les les rythmes scolaires est une bonne
idée nous défendons un projet de
transformation de l'école mais cette
transformation doit être doit se
traduire par une amélioration à la fois
des conditions de travail des élèves
bien entendu mais aussi des conditions
de travail des enseignants or le décret
proposé par le ministre de l'éducation
nationale Vincent payon n'apporte pas
suffisamment de garantiese selon ce
syndicat d'enseignant là on a plutôt à
faire un calendrier qui se fait à marche
forcée donc qui a peu de chance de
comment dirais-je de permettre
l'élaboration de projets construits et
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que
l'association des mares de France
d'ailleurs s'est aussi prononcer contre
la mise en place à la rentrée 2013 les
maires de gauche comme de droite estime
que les délais imposés par le décret
sont difficiles à tenir pour la rentrée
prochaine les budgets pour 2013 étant
déjà votés à guillancour par exemple le
maire socialiste François de Ligier a
déjà programmé la modification des
rythmes scolaires pour 2014 de son côté
l'académie de Versailles annonce la
création de 74 postes d'enseignants pour
septembre prochain dans le 1emer
degréén